all right uh mr trump thank you so much
for joining us uh we're here
in nevada nevada is we are only two days
away from election day how much of a
priority
is nevada in this campaign and what's
your message to nevada voters
specifically
well i'm here with two days left so it's
obviously a pretty good priority but you
know so are all states
the reality is for us we don't have the
luxury of a mainstream media that will
do our campaigning for us you know joe
biden gets that he can hide in the
basement he can call a lid at 8 30 in
the morning every day
doesn't matter they'll campaign for them
we don't have that benefit so what we
have to do is come out and talk about
donald trump's track record of
accomplishment
when you compare donald trump's
accomplishments to joe biden's 47 years
in the swamp with zero accomplishment
that anyone could certainly name
it's amazing he created the strongest
economy america has ever seen
the lowest unemployment numbers
america's ever seen the highest number
of new startup businesses
the guy that can do that is the guy that
can do it again he got peace deals four
piece deals done in the middle east
that's unheard of
he's pulling us out of the endless wars
he's taking on big pharma because he's
not owned by everyone like you know the
bidens are
because so he can do what's right for
america so he's taking on the consumer
drug pricing issue
so that they're not selling drugs in
europe for two cents on the dollar while
gouging americans he's saying that's not
going to fly
in donald trump's america so donald
trump is fighting those battles for the
american people and i think they've seen
the results
uh like i mentioned very close to the
election nevada has the option to do
mainland voting it's been expanded this
year you know you continue to including
on stage tonight kind of
cast doubt on the mail-in process yes
what you know there's
there's a lot of doubt in the mailing
process when it's passed you know at two
o'clock in the morning
unbeknownst to anyone else uh they said
there'd be signature verification but
there isn't really signature
verification there's sort of a sham
process that doesn't actually do the
signification
yeah that is a problem i mean again
places like florida where they've done
absentee voting to that extent
for long periods of time i'm totally
fine with the systems but when you sort
of
jam a system down people are getting
multiple ballots you know
less than one percent of the things are
being kicked out uh
and they're essentially eliminating what
they were promised yeah
that does smell really fishy to me and
it should anyone else who wants fair
elections
what about you know the investigations
that have been done that say that
there's no widespread evidence of voter
fraud
and here in nevada there's been 90
million ballots cast today
you think they're they're checking each
one of these things they're they're
going through all of that
how come they're finding ballots in some
states in ditches uh amazingly enough
all these absentee ballots from the
military which they know are going to
skew heavily towards trump those are the
ones that magically disappear
you know if this wasn't a recurring
theme if it wasn't happening all over
the place
you know i'd be much more uh okay with
it
but it is and it seems designed to be
able to play with results
uh speaking of kind of the the mixed
messaging that we're kind of hearing
you and the president continuing to say
we're rounding the corner
we're uh you know basically downplaying
the virus when we're seeing you know i'm
downplaying the virus we're looking at
actual numbers
if you look at where the u.s is trending
relative to the rest of the world we've
gotten ahead of this
when you look at the damage that would
be done by doing the endless lockdown
shutting down the entire country joe
biden's plan let's shut down the country
for three years
you lose your job you lose your
livelihood you lose your home your
marriage
turned to drugs and alcohol the damage
that would be done from that is far
worse than anything the virus could do
now they have therapeutics
they're about to come out with the
vaccine we've rounded the corner without
question
but the democrats don't want that they
want that fear again if you lose your
job
hey they got a government program for
you that's what the democrats are all
about they'll put you on a government
program you'll be dependent on them
forever and you'll vote democrat
for life so when you look at what's
actually going on there
there's a good thing you can be
responsible you can wash your hands
if you're one of those people one of the
small number of people
that are at risk yeah take the extra
precaution by all means
if you have pre-existing conditions do
that it's amazing i look at the
statistics
i put up a bunch of the graphs from the
cdc i just extrapolated put them into
excel format and it's very different
message
they talk about new cases are through
the yeah because they're doing a
thousand times more testing
because now they have the rapid test
kits and they're available so cases go
through the roof but
the death rate relative to that is
coming down significantly
right they said last year we had 75 000
flu deaths in america this year they
said it's less than 1 000.
does anyone really believe that the flu
magically disappeared the flu is not
killing people anymore it's only coveted
i don't believe that for a second about
your recent comments that say you know
deaths are almost nothing when
again the death rate is going down on a
relative basis to proportion so of
course they're going to spend that out
of control but the reality is
we can't afford to shut down this
country again we can't afford to have
our children learning from
an iphone for two minutes a day while
not paying attention
that would do far more damage than
anything the virus had donald trump
promised a v shape recovery we got it
you saw the gdp growth the highest ever
recorded in america 33 and a third
percent
it went up if you shut down this country
again and you do the lockdowns those
businesses that managed to spring back
they're never opening their doors again
millions of people would be out of work
and the damage that that would cause
because of joe biden and the idiocy that
they're pushing in
the blue states with governors that are
just fine
would do far more damage than anything
the virus would ever do i do just want
to ask one more question i have to go
apologize
thank you so much appreciate it